now in order to be eligible you must
have received a modernity dose at a
health district location between january
4th
and january 9th it's very specific joe
mohler is live at the convention center
with more on this and also the
frustrations stemming from the
appointment booking website people just
can't get through joe
a lot of people having problems a lot of
people reaching out to us regarding the
difficulties about making that second
dose appointment
obviously as you can imagine people are
concerned about this well the health
district is now saying they are sending
out
emails regarding more appointments and
here at the convention center
they say over the next four weeks they
will be having walk-ups for the second
dose
you know i'm over 75 i have cancer
i'm on chemo john burgess says getting a
second dose appointment for the vaccine
has been impossible for him the date
that they put on the back
for february 11. he says the website
says nothing is available until the end
of march
i've spoken to a lot of people in my
boat and they're just saying forget i'm
not even going to get the second shot
thursday the health district announced
walk-ins will be accepted at the
convention center but it only applies to
those who received the modern vaccine at
a health district location
between january 4th and 9th i think you
should try to get
that date or as close to it as possible
vaccine expert from e7 health dr
jonathan bechtari recommends sticking
close to the second dose date
but as we are seeing scheduling issues
the health district says you have a
window from the first dose
they said six weeks i think that's a
window that
is there and extrapolated based on what
we know of other vaccines what we know
from the astrozenica vaccine for example
i'm back out here live the number on
your screen here is the number for the
hotline regarding these second toes and
we know many are frustrated they just
want to talk to somebody
on the phone and many have been having
issues with that in line as well but
that is the number the health district
is giving us as far as the walk-ins
happening here at the convention center
they will be from 8 a.m until
2 p.m and it's only for those who
receive the modern vaccine between
january 4th
and 9th and again it all depends on
availability
reporting live at the convention center
this evening joe moore 8 news now